the superhero life isn't cheap luckily
many of marvel's most powerful heroes
have plenty of cash to burn from literal
gods with untold fortunes to billionaire
investors and landed aristocrats these
are the richest heroes in the marvel
universe
joey chapman is the latest in a long
line of english heroes who have fought
evil as union jack while the previous
union jacks were part of the wealthy
fallsworth family chapman was born into
the working class and earned his mask
through a baptism by fire chapman's
entry into the fallsworth family comes
through his best friend kenneth crichton
creighton is the grandson of lord brian
fallsworth who fought alongside the team
known as the invaders in world war ii
shortly after crichton reveals this to
chapman the vampire baron blood
infiltrates the fallsworth mansion
chapman dons the costume and proves his
worth in battle against the vampire
leading kenneth to suggest that it
should be chapman who carries on the
union jack tradition despite his humble
beginnings chapman's access to the
fallsworth fortune and his own work with
the british secret service affords him
plenty of resources to pursue his fight
against evil this wealth helps pay for
his numerous gadgets his bulletproof
costume and barrel his high-tech
motorcycle
steven strange begins his super heroic
journey by spending all the wealth he
earned as a surgeon on anything that
might heal his hands 3d printing a
scaffold if i could get a loan together
just
small though just 200 000. you've always
spent money as fast as you can make it
but now you're spending money you don't
even have
becoming a master of the mystic arts
eventually mends his broken digits and
it makes him rich again too dr strange's
wealth is made most clear in the
ownership and upkeep of his greenwich
village sanctum sanctorum and the long
employment of his faithful friend and
comrade in arms wong there are plenty of
other obvious examples of his wealth
lying around his home too while many of
the antiques and artifacts in his vast
collection are no doubt the product of
adventure some of them were just as
likely purchased by strange himself
moreover in 1989's doctor strange
sorcerer supreme number 11 readers
learned strange owns a nearby warehouse
for the sole purpose of storing the
cryogenically frozen corpse of his
brother victor earlier in that series
strange's pockets proved deep enough for
his friend sarah wolfe to set up a
memorial foundation in his name after he
is believed to have died
as any fan of highlander will know
living for many centuries is a surefire
way to get rich this is a lesson well
learned by the eons old ulysses
bloodstone a caveman saddled with a
mythical stone that gives him both his
surname and his unnaturally long life
ulysses spends his considerable time on
earth hunting monsters and searching for
luxel quante sin the creature who
destroyed his ancient tribe ulysses
eventually finds both vengeance and his
long-awaited eternal reward but not
before siring a daughter in 2001's
bloodstone number one marvel introduced
elsa bloodstone who learns of her
father's fantastic past while settling
his estate not long after with the help
of the fabled gem her father left her
and a solid set of superpowers elsa
follows in her father's footsteps elso
also inherited ulysses massive fortune
upon his death her first solo series was
short-lived but she continues to use her
wealth to fund her crusade against the
world's monsters perhaps most memorably
in the acclaimed series next wave agents
of hate
janet van dyne better known as the wasp
begins her crime fighting career after
the death of her father vernon vernon
was a world renowned inventor at the
time of his death and his demise not
only inspires janet to become a hero but
also gifts her with a ton of cash and
she's not shy about it either early on
in her avenging days janet is known both
among her teammates and the public as a
socialite and an incorrigible flirt not
to mention a fashion plate and although
she later curbs her more extravagant
impulses janet never entirely loses her
love of the finer things in life a
fashion designer whose career pre-dates
her time as an avenger janet uses her
fortune to further her art she changes
her costumes so often that it's not all
that rare to see her in one outfit in
one issue and a different one in the
next her designs can also be glimpsed in
other corners of the marvel universe for
example carolina dean can be spotted
wearing van dyne branded clothing in the
2017 runaways comic series
often when new writers and artists are
assigned superheroes who have never been
particularly popular those creators like
to shake up the character's essential
traits mark spector aka moon knight is a
perfect example of this as recent takes
on the character have tended to minimize
the fact that this mentally splintered
superhero is a bona fide billionaire
long before he became the fist of konchu
spectre was a renowned mercenary and
heavyweight boxing champion by the time
he begins fighting evil as moon knight
his investments have yielded some
serious rewards while his resources are
not inherited as bruce waynes are
spectre's wealth is one of the reasons
some fans see him as marvel's answer to
batman not only does he mostly work at
night but his wealth also affords him an
arsenal of themed weapons vehicles
gadgets and costumes and sure he's not
as widely known in the marvel universe
as batman is within the world of dc
comics but moon knight isn't to be
underestimated dude has a moon copter
after all
[Music]
honestly charles
i don't know how you survived
living in such hardship
little of the good charles xavier has
done for mutant kind would have been
possible without his considerable wealth
indeed the grounds and the mansion used
for xavier's school for gifted
youngsters is inherited from his father
that fortune was likewise used to build
the more secret areas of xavier's school
such as the danger room in addition to
the x-men's vast variety of high-tech
vehicles thanks to a story from the
early 2000s we know that at that time
charles xavier's net worth was 3.5
billion dollars this is revealed in
2002's new x-men number 129 when the
artificially evolved mutant known as
phantom x tries to extort xavier of
course it's likely that xavier's fortune
has increased considerably since 2002
not only is the founder of the x-men
known for investing wisely but the 2019
event dawn of x likely did a lot of good
for xavier's bottom line in this arc
xavier helps to found a new sovereign
mutant state on the sentient mutant
island of krakowa a process that
includes brokering lucrative deals with
other nations who are seeking medicines
only available on krakowa warren
worthington iii has often acted as one
of the x-men's deepest pockets having
inherited billions from his family as
well as ownership of worthington
industries archangel funds everything
from missions to equipment in fact it
has not been unheard of for charles
xavier himself to borrow money from
archangel in order to make repairs
additions and improvements to his
westchester school financially speaking
warren is also solely responsible for
the founding of the first version of
x-factor the team set up by the original
x-men to hunt and secretly help mutants
on the run it's warren who bankrolls
their equipment their headquarters and
their new uniforms warren's history has
often worked against his resources
however such as when his board of
directors uses his temporary amnesia to
take the company from him thankfully in
2012's wolverine and the x-men number 19
warren successfully takes back his
family's company with a little help from
ace attorney matt murdock of course
daniel rand is more than just a master
of kung fu and the hard-won wielder of
the iron fist he's also ceo of the rand
corporation a position which has
afforded rand and his allies many
comforts and advantages but it has also
attracted plenty of new enemies
originally the rand meacham corporation
the company passes briefly into the care
of harold meacham daniel's father's old
business partner wendell rand had
visited the mystical city of conlon once
upon a time and searches for it in the
snows of tibet years later with his son
wife and mitchum in tow disaster strikes
however and when wendell hangs
helplessly from the edge of a precipice
meacham turns on him and throws him to
his death daniel's mother heather
subsequently sacrifices herself to save
daniel from hungry wolves allowing the
young danny rand to find shelter and
more in kunlun as an adult dany returns
to new york city and regains control of
rand though his revenge on meacham is
stolen from him by an assassin he has
since used his vast wealth to fund his
work as the immortal iron fist including
funding the heroes for hire an
organization rand and luke cage founded
to help fight crime
kyle richmond aka knighthawk is perhaps
the most obscure of marvel's wealthy
heroes as part of the squadron sinister
he was originally a villainous batman
clone in a group of villains blatantly
modeled after dc comics justice league
he later changes sides most prominently
as regular in marvel's first defender
series like many rich marvel heroes kyle
richmond inherited his wealth from his
father in this case arthur richmond
owner of richmond enterprises nighthawk
doesn't always prove to be a vigilant
owner of the company he inherited
however while he's busy first committing
crime and then fighting it he allows his
friend j.c pennysworth to handle the
reigns penny's worth is later revealed
to be the head of the racist terror
group the sons of the serpent which
makes you wonder if nighthawk really did
his due diligence on the guy richmond
subsequently uses his wealth to
establish the richmond riding academy
which doubles as a base of operations
for the defenders or at least it's
intended to serve as such with team
members hulk and dr strange often not
showing up for work richmond complains
about all the money he spent for nothing
particularly on the oversized conference
chair he had made for the hulk
while professor x's history is not
without its moral ambiguity marvel
comics canon has long maintained that he
never uses his psychic abilities to help
with his investments however xavier
isn't marvel's only psychic and they
don't all share his principles emma
frost certainly isn't afraid to use her
formidable telepathy to gain an edge in
the financial world it's likely a good
chunk of her wealth may come from even
sketchier ventures frost is after all
the former white queen of the hellfire
club which is not known for its respect
of the law emma is the heiress to the
frost fortune including frost
international which specializes in
technology and electronics when the
x-men establish the mutant safe haven of
utopia it's frost's wealth alone that
supports the island her power has grown
considerably in recent years too with
almost the entire population of earth's
mutants having joined the sovereign
nation of krakowa frost's position on
the island's quiet council is a lofty
perch indeed
reed richards isn't exactly obsessed
with hoarding wealth put him in a lab
and give him the chance to explore the
cosmos and you've got a happy mr
fantastic but believe it or not the
upkeep of an active portal to the
negative zone and the storage space for
a fleet of fantastic cars isn't cheap so
it's a good thing richards also happens
to be one of marvel's wealthiest heroes
richard wasn't always wealthy but the
patents for the inventions he churns out
not to mention the merchandising rights
for the fantastic four bring in the big
bucks still reed is the kind of guy who
doesn't see his riches until they're
gone thus he and the rest of the
fantastic four are hit hard when their
property is seized in an early 2000s
storyline after doctor doom is dragged
to hell the team dismantles the
government of latviria in the hopes of
undoing doom's years of tyranny when
they return home their assets are seized
by the government because of their
unsanctioned invasion of a foreign
nation it isn't until richard emerges as
one of the most prominent pro-government
heroes in civil war that the united
states releases their stranglehold on
his property
unlike many of the richest marvel heroes
sable didn't inherit anything from her
family unless you count the skills she's
used to become one of the world's most
well-known mercenaries her father
trained her to fight after the murder of
her mother and sable went on to found
her own soldier for hire company silver
sable international silver sable's
wealth is enough to afford her the
acquisition of high-tech weaponry and a
vast variety of other equipment made
from cutting-edge materials it is also
enough to allow her to hire other
world-class mercenaries including
super-powered operatives although she
can be cutthroat in business sable
doesn't amass her riches for rich's sake
much of her wealth goes to aid her
homeland the fictional nation of
simcaria
like thor the marvel hero hercules isn't
just a modern day strong man with a love
of greco-roman myth he's the genuine god
and his long life has afforded him some
very deep pockets this is never more
clear than upon the news of his
temporary death in 2010's hercules fall
of an avenger number one when venus and
nomura do the hard work of closing out
hercules estate they learn he was one of
the first investors in stark industries
he initially invested a hundred thousand
dollars in the young company and at the
time of the strong man's death that
investment was worth quote a second line
of zeros he also owns a large number of
breweries and wineries as well as
apartments and homes all across the
globe and while hercules is one of the
richest heroes in marvel it seems that
he himself may not even know it as venus
and nomura discover that he apparently
forgot about most of his investments if
ever there were a superhero in need of
an accountant it's this guy
big man in a suit of armor
take that off what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist
when you think of rich marvel heroes
it's a sure bet that you'll probably
think of tony stark he may have
inherited his huge fortune and stark
industries from his father howard but
stark can't be accused of sitting on his
laurels in fact it's likely that no
single person has more to do with the
upkeep of the avengers than tony stark
more often than not his wealth has
financed the team even before he reveals
his secret identity to his colleagues
and later the public at large it's stark
who owns avengers mansion it's stark who
employs their butler edwin jarvis and
it's stark who pays for and designs the
team's quinjets not to mention of course
the considerable amount of time money
and resources stark puts towards
designing and building his many iron man
suits nor the innovations he's created
for other heroes such as spider-man's
famous iron spider suit
there are characters whose wealth is
almost impossible to quantify because
their existence is utterly incomparable
to anything in the real world black bolt
medusa and the rest of the inhuman royal
family are a perfect example of this the
inhumans are a subspecies of humanity
that was experimented upon by the alien
cree millennia ago a process that
granted them extraordinary abilities and
access to stunning amounts of wealth
having made homes in both the himalayas
and on the blue area of the moon the
royal family claims real estate holdings
that are entirely priceless they also
have in their possession advanced cree
technology which plenty of earth's
militaries would pay dearly to get their
hands on finally the family possesses
the terrigen crystals which are counted
among the rarest materials in the solar
system
neymar the king of atlantis claims all
of the earth's oceans as his kingdom and
according to him the ships that traverse
them are only allowed to do so because
of his charity while few world leaders
recognize namor's claim to two-thirds of
the earth's surface he certainly has the
muscle to back it up when you're a super
powered world ruler in marvel comics
losing your throne becomes kind of a big
deal as such namor has found himself
dethroned more times than anyone can
count yet even without a kingdom the
submariner has managed to secure
significant wealth for himself early in
the 90s neymar the submariner series for
example namor reinvents himself as a
businessman by using various treasures
from the deep the fortune these rarities
bring him allows him to found oracle inc
with the intention of using its wealth
to heal the environment
no organization on earth could surpass
wakanda in terms of net worth and no
individual could top t'challa the king
of wakanda and the superhero known as
black panther though the 2016 black
panther series sees t'challa's power as
ruler rendered less absolute by a new
democratic government he still has more
control over his nation's wealth than
any other single person the source of
the nation's wealth is vibranium a
substance that cannot be found in
significant amounts anywhere else on
earth vibranium is the most versatile
metal on earth and has helped to make
wakanda not only the richest but also
the most technologically advanced nation
on the planet while t'challa doesn't
often flex his financial muscles it's
not unheard of either for example in the
2002 black panther storyline enemy of
the state 2 in which he finds himself at
cross purposes with tony stark t'challa
stages a hostile takeover of stark
enterprises with seemingly no effort at
all
there are some riches whose worth cannot
be properly counted with numbers and
many of them are the property of thor
the god of thunder slow down a little
bit there's a few people in the room
that don't understand
not me i get it
in 2019 store number 16 odin steps aside
allowing thor to become the new
all-father and the king of asgard once
that happens every drop of gold in the
land in the golden realm becomes the
property of the mighty thor as well as
all the artifacts locked away in odin's
vaults one of the most valuable
artifacts in thor's collection is the
one he's known best for his iconic
hammer mjolnir while it's best known for
its ability to summon and control
lightning the hammer's versatility is
equally impressive not to mention the
fact that the odenson is one of only a
handful of people who have been able to
wield the weapon at all chances are
there's no marvel weapon out there with
a higher price tag check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about marvel comics are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]